For our first train machine example
I've chosen one that tests the oddness
of a binary representation
of a natural number.
Note that I've cheated here
in the transition function
by including only state
symbol pairs in the domain,
though we would actually
encounter during computation.
By convention,
if no transition is specified for
the current state symbol pair Then the
program just halts in the reject state.
One convenient way to represent
the transition function,
by the way, is with a state diagram.
Similar to what is often used for
finite automata for
those familiar with that
model of computation.
Each state gets its own
vertex in a multi-graph and
every row of the transition
table is represented as an edge.
The edge gets labeled with the remaining
information besides the two states.
That is, it gets the symbol read,
followed by an arrow,
then the symbol to write, and
the direction to move the head.
Now, let's trace through the operation
of this turning machine on this input,
1, 0, 1, 1.
The head first reads a 1 from the tape,
and we're in the state q0.
So I go up here and
consult the transition table.
And here,
I see that I should follow this edge,
since that has state q0,
and we read a one.
And this transition tells me
that I should write a 1 or
leave the table alone, and
move the head to the right.
And change the state to q0.
So let's go ahead and update our figure.
We're still in state q0.
And the position of the head has
been moved one space to the right.
So this becomes our new configuration.
And the next step, will be to 0.
Comes up in the transition diagram.
We see that this means that we
should leave the 0 alone and
move the head to the right again.
And stand state to 0.
We read the 1 from the tape and that
means we follow this transition here and
move the head to the right again.
And the next step is similar.
Finally, the head reads a blank symbol.
The transition table tells us
to write a blank symbol and
move the head to the left.
And to switch the state to q1.
Now we read the symbol under the head.
That's a 1.
So we follow this transition rule here
and we end up in an accept state.